Man, I can't believe the boss just did that!
What happened? What's wrong?
He didn't give me the promotion that he had promised me.
Again? Didn't the same thing happen last year?
Yes, it did.
I've had it with him and with this place.
I don't blame you for feeling that way, but...
No really, I can't take being treated like this anymore.
I totally understand how you feel.
The more I think about it, the more furious I get.
You've been here for a long time and have always done a great job.
More than that!
Every time he asked me to stay late, or do extra work,...
...I've always done it!
Did you remind him of that?
Of course! Do you think it did any good?
I guess not. I'm really sorry.